turning now to the highly anticipated
new season of the hugely popular series
and let me say that again because it's
hugely popular Yellowstone season number
five trailer for The Western drama set
records just with the trailer wow with
more than 14 million views in the first
24 hours wow TV's number one show
follows the Dutton family who owned the
largest cattle ranch in the United
States as they fight their enemies to
protect their land and family Legacy
American Sniper actor I remember Luke in
this Luke Grimes he's Casey Dutton the
son of John Dutton played by Kevin
Costner his wife Monica is played by
Fargo actor that's Kelsey asbell this is
oh look at her this is a clip
hey you coming home uh it looks like
we're gonna have to take these horses
back to Billings
thinking maybe I should meet you
meet you they're getting worse
that's three weeks early
they're really bad Casey I'm leaving now
you don't think you can wait
should okay well I don't want you giving
birth on the side of the road I'll sit
in an ambulance South okay meet you on
the road okay okay
and now what happens after that phone
call we cannot say Yellowstone Arizona
Paramount Network which as you probably
know by now CBS is part of Paramount
Global we're happy to say that Luke
Grimes and Kelsey asbell are here in the
studio welcome to Superstars welcome
because I want to know what this ride is
like for you because it started as a
sleeper hit and now it is ginormous
start us off Kelsey about how you're
processing it you too Luke oh it just
means to you I I don't think we have
processed it really it's it's wild
yeah I mean it's it's this has been a
life-changing job and experience I think
but you know we both feel really lucky
to be a part of it and and really love
making it so does it feel different
making it after it blows up right
because you do season one it gets
renewed season two and then it's popular
it gets renewed and then it really takes
off during the pandemic and now you've
got 14 million views for the trailer
trailer in like half a day right I mean
does that change the feeling of going
and acting and doing the job
I guess it just changes the airport
experience that way there
everything else kind of feels the same
time
the haircut so
that's how important experience but you
know at the end of season four Luke you
you went away for self-reflection he
came back Kelsey and he says I see the
end of us it was that was Heavy that was
very happy yeah and you are known as a
very emotional character you are not a
crybab cry baby man thank you but but
you do tend to be a little emotional in
in your scene sure yeah I mean uh it's
it's sort of part of where he's at right
he's always kind of between this rock
and a hard place and between his dad and
his wife that's sort of his his
storyline his Arc what decisions he
gonna make and I can't wait to find out
either yeah sorry you started out both
of you as like Romeo and Juliet I know
people have said that but that makes me
nervous because Romeo and Juliet has a
really really sad and tragic ending I
hope I'm not giving anything away
[Laughter]
um and you guys are tested almost all
the jump yeah yeah I mean well now we're
in a survival movie it's really um yeah
it's Against All Odds but I feel like
this season it really it kind of
redefines our relationship to the family
and and our part and its Legacy
absolutely yeah uh Luke the they're kind
of two kinds of people in Hollywood
right there are people who like watching
their own stuff right and there are
people who've never seen themselves for
whatever reason they don't do it you're
of the I don't watch myself variety is
that true and why it's less about not
watching myself it's more about I really
want to enjoy this whole series one day
when I'm not doing it anymore and I feel
like if I watch it now it's just gonna
get me in my head I'm gonna be judging
what I'm doing I'm not going to be able
to enjoy the story so I feel like one
once I'm totally done with this and I
can put it away years later I'll sit
down and really be able to enjoy it is
that your approach to all things that
you're in
no I mean sometimes I have to watch
things at premieres so I've seen enough
I've seen enough to know what I do so
I'm good I'm good and Chelsea what I
think is so great about your characters
that you grew up on an Indian
Reservation that's a lot of the conflict
between the duttons and the Indian
reservation and you say that these are
important stories to tell yeah of course
I mean I think the Western genre you
know we're really used to The Good the
Bad and yes of course no one's ugly on
Yellowstone but I think that um I I
offer exhibit a right exactly
including mine
but no I think what Taylor Sheridan does
so beautifully is he puts two groups of
people in conversation with each other
and and uses the entertainment medium to
really talk about issues especially
native issues that matter yeah it's an
important you know one of the things I
love about the show and I'm I've watched
every episode uh multiple times I'll
watch the spin-off
um it's that it doesn't shy away from
the important issues I think it would be
easy as you say to sort of present good
versus evil or good and bad but it does
there it shows that there are Shades
even when people do horrible things on
the show
you kind of understand it
looks like yeah here it's good I'm gonna
watch it one day yeah yeah I can't wait
I have no idea
I think that's kind of the beauty of it
right there's no there's no good guy
there's no bad guy there's no villain
and I think that's just really good
storytelling and at any point someone
can can do something wrong and also be
righteous and you're trying to figure
out like who does deserve this and
what's going on here yeah I do find
myself going back and forth but you like
it so much you've moved to Montana Mr
Grimes I have yeah wow it's hard to
spend that much time there and not fall
in love with it I mean as she knows I
mean we're there you know four or five
months out of the year and I just then
going back to LA felt very strange and
had to move up there so all right I like
The Good The Bad and nobody's ugly
bless you of the Set uh Luke Grimes
that's very true very true thank you
both very much season five of
Yellowstone Premiere Sunday November
13th on Paramount Network